hey everybody this is Jimmy with bright
insight all right guys look at these
photos no you were not shown these
photos when you were growing up in
school and neither was I and by the way
no they're not showing these types of
photographs in the textbooks that our
children are actively being taught today
in the public school system as well as
people at the university level now what
you're seeing here are various stone
structures carved out of rose granite as
well as basalt now just to put this in
perspective these types of stone
materials cannot be cut and carved with
the materials that we know that the
dynastic Egyptians had for example you
need steel to cut these types of stone
materials and later in the presentation
I'm going to show you what's called the
Mohs scale of hardness that basically
details the hardness of level of
different types of stones so for example
rose granite what you're seeing here is
a seven out of ten you need steel to cut
that basalt is approximately a six and a
half there is no way that the dynastic
Egyptians were able to cut and carve
these types of materials utilizing the
bronze chisels that they we know that
they had or the dolerite hammers that we
also know that they were using so those
meant to emphasize that fact look at the
precision now if you were to use a
bronze chisel on these types of
materials it would be like the
equivalent of trying to shape and cut
wood with wood it's just not going to
work and when you look at the incredible
accuracy of these of these structures in
the right angles as well as the circular
drill bits like how do you cut circles
like that through solid stone through
rose granite you know hard that is a
seven out of ten on the Mohs scale I
mean guys you know how hard granite is
not knock on your countertops with your
bare knuckles and let me know what that
feels like and as you look through these
photos you have definitive evidence that
there is some sort of lost ancient high
technology or machining that was
utilized to cut these stones there's no
other way there's no way that they were
using stone hammers from dolerite to
make these types of cuts it's just not
possible and you can see the definitive
evidence where
you can see the actual lines where the
steps in the recut surfaces and the
angle cuts of the sauce like hello
that's please are clearly saw cuts hello
that did they have that type of machine
machinery back in the dynastic Egyptian
the time no we know that they didn't
guys this is common sense
the evidence is right in front of us and
there is an active attempt to keep this
under wraps because again they're not
putting this type of information in
textbooks but we now have hundreds of
geologists in stonemasons throughout the
world that are doing active
demonstrations and you can find these
videos on YouTube by the way and by the
way real quick special thanks to Google
Images and everyone that put these
images on there because that's where I
source these images so thank you I'm
utilizing them to help teach you guys
things but there are people throughout
the world including John Anthony West
Robert Schoch Brian Forrester um Graham
Hancock Randall Carson and many others
that are actively talking about this but
you also have professional stonemasons
and geologists that are showing you
videos trying to recreate and and and
carve these types of stone structures
out of what the dynastic Egyptians have
and they're in there laughing they're
saying it's not possible there's no way
and what we're actively being told and
we're taught and is still being taught
in the education system does not account
for how these types of structures were
made and you can see it right here
with your own eyes I mean look at this
like here so here's photographs of you
know these types of these tools which I
showed you before how could they have
done it and we look at this stone box
here as an example look at the precision
on this and it's completely
unexplainable look at the circular drill
holes look at these very unique cuts in
carved scoop marks in this grows granite
solid rose bedrock granite and I'll have
another video on this regarding the
obelisk because that's really was these
were taken from the Aswan Currie in
Egypt but not to mention I mean look at
these ginormous stone blocks not just
precision on them but look how enormous
they are and we're talking 20 30 tons on
many of these so it's not just how could
they cut and carve them or move them but
how did they lift them do they have a
crane I mean there's many different
theories and
this was done but they do not stand up
they get debunked in the the theories
that we were taught with you know these
leather robes in 20,000 slaves do not do
not account for the actual definitive
evidence of sockets that you can see
here as well as drill drill holes and
not to mention these these circular you
know oval type shapes that you can see
right here in front of you where and
these con caves like how do you how
could you get a bunch of stone you know
hammers and make that type of shape how
can you even do that with a chisel even
with a steel chisel I would say that you
would not be able to grind it to that
type of degree without some sort of
advanced machinery look guys the
evidence is right in front of us you
decide again I'm Jimmy this is right
inside if you'd like what I have to say
well I can subscribe I have many more
videos for you enjoy and many more to
come help me spread the message be
blessed all